die Justiz ist gerade ein bisschen überlastet
nicht wah aber ich keine Sorge wir haben ganz
starke Institutionen in diesem Land nicht
war unsere Demokratie ist wehrhaft hat auch
mein Therapeut gesagt und wir leben in einem
Rechtsstaat nicht wah Frau Richterin wenn die
Fische tot sind ermorde ich dann den Hamster
weil ich die Richterin bin ja vielleicht zeige
ich Ihnen das besser mal nehmen wir an das
worstce Szenario ist ein treten die CDU ist
implodiert und auf eine kümmerliche Größe
geschrumpft und die AFD ist mit absoluter
Mehrheit in den Deutschen Bundestag eingezogen
vielen vielen Dank für eure Stimme Deutschland
Deutschland so dann würde ich sagen dann bestücken
wir mal das Bundeskanzleramt so sie haben Recht
da stimmt was nicht Moment so jetzt ist gut
jetzt jetzt bräuchte ich noch eine First Lady
sie überlegt sich es noch dann mache ich jetzt
erstmal hier eine kleine Wahlrechtsreform hat
die Ampel ja auch gemacht sagen wir mal deutsche
mit ausländischen vor und Nachnamen dürfen nicht
mehr wählen nee also dann gehe ich auf die Straße
aber du heißt fridulin Müller betrifft mich ja gar
nicht ne ich bin ja noch da der Vorschlag
der AFD ist ohnehin verfassungswidrig und
wird abgelehnt ich dachte wir haben jetzt die
Mehrheit können wir nicht dank dieser Mehrheit
diese Barbara sisch da drüben mal absetzen
eben nicht nicht wahr in der Demokratie gibt
es ja Gewaltenteilung nicht W unsere Justiz ist
unabhängig natürlich auch die beiden Senate des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes ich hö immer unabhängig
aber hier sehe ich schon wieder Parteifarben diese
Richterinnen nicht wahr achten darauf dass auch
die AFD Mehrheit mit ihrer Politik sich an die
Verfassung hält ich weiß nicht worüber ich mich
mehr künstlich aufregen sollte darüber dass sie
haben oder dass da zwei grüne sitzen das sind ja
keine grünen nicht war die sind von der Partei die
Grünen nominiert worden die Grünen besetzen des
Bundesverfassungsgericht mit ihren Gefolgsleuten
das berichtet ihr wieder nicht im staatshunk
jemand der Bundestag ernennt nun mal die Hälfte
der Verfassungsrichter ach so dann könn ich
die Hälfte rausschmeißen mit meinenevolgsleuten
besetzen nein um Verfassungsrichter innen zu
ernennen bräuchten sie im Parlament eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit Z Mist die habe ich nicht
na ja brauchen sie Grunde auch gar nicht
bitte na ja die die die Tatsache dass man für die
Ernennung von Verfassungsrichter innen eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit braucht die kann ja durch ein
Bundesgesetz geändert werden Bundesgesetz okay
was brauche ich dafür da reichte theoretisch
eine einfache Mehrheit die habe ich wieso haben
sie ih denn das jetzt verraten die Demokratie
Transparenz ist auch eine meiner Werte hat mein
Therapeut gesagt sehr gut dann mache ich jetzt
jetzt mal ein schönes Bundesgesetz mit einfacher
Mehrheit und zwar sage ich dass in Zukunft die
Besetzung der Verfassungsrichter mit einfacher
Mehrheit stattfinden kann mich werden Sie
so schnell nicht los meine Kolleginnen und
ich sind noch bis 2035 im Amt nein Mami kommt
früher heim Bundesverfassungsgericht sieht ein
bisschen überlastet aus ja finde ich auch finde
man man könnte i auch ein bisschen unter die Arme
greifen ja ja wie wie wie na ja man könnte z.B
einfach ein einen dritten Senat einführen was
na ja ein dritten Senat nicht wahr und an den
lagert sie alle Fragen auf aus die sich um das
Staatsorganisationsrecht drehen dritten und
wie was brauch ich dazu um das zu machen na
ja eine einfache Mehrheit die habe ich und WE
mal D kann ich ja wieder mit ne da kann ich ja
wieder mit dir einfach meht da kann ich ja quasi
die Richter wieder hier besetzen die Hälfte ne
theoretisch ja Moment das hilft mir nichts es
gibt ja immer noch diese anderen zwei Senate
oben drüber schon aber schauen Sie wenn die die
Bundesländer bend desverfassungsgericht klagen
nicht wah weil die Gesetze der AFD vielleicht
Länder in länderkompetenzen eingreifen dann
landet das Ganze vor meinem blauen Senat weil da
ja alle Fragen der Staatsorganisation verhandelt
werden danke schön ah dann machen wir doch
jetzt gleich mal ein paar AFD Reformen und
zwar verfassungskonforme ich habe da mal
demokratiethoretische Frage ja gerne ja
sind sie dumm nein nein ich habe mich in
Sache schlau gemacht ja bei den Juristen
vom verfassungsblock Spezialisten nicht W und die
haben das alles durchgespielt aber wie können sie
denn da so ruhig bleiben ja weil er damit ja nicht
durchkommt die Hälfte dieser dieses dritten Senats
wird ja ernannt vom Bundesrat nicht war und die
achten dann darauf ja dass die Gesetze der AFD
verfassungsmäßig sind und sollten die mal nicht
verfassungsmäßig sein nicht war dann wird die
Verfassungswidrigkeit ganz einfach festgestellt
nicht war durch fünf der acht Richter 1 2 3
fünf wissen Sie ich glaube nicht dass einer meiner
Richter meine Reform für verfassungswidrig halten
wird haben sie gerade ganz demokratisch das
Verfassungsgericht ausgehebelt na ja na ja
Moment es gibt ja noch den den Bundespräsidenten
und dieser Bundespräsident muss in unserem Land
alle Gesetze unterzeichnen und ich glaube
nicht dass unser Bundespräsident AFD Politik
umsetzt ich weiß nicht da muss ich den bundesu
irgendwie falsch verstanden haben na dann dann
der Herr steinmeierer hat sich oft von der AFD
distanziert ja ja ja das sagt er oft aber dann
hat er tatsächlich Kerne unseres Parteiprogramms
übernommen haben sie ih gesehen bei der mioskaa
gucken Sie mal aber in den Umfragen erfahren wir
auch dass die Menschen die die AFD wählen sagen
ich ma das weil die benennen diese Probleme und
deswegen beharre ich auf der Begrenzung es ist
doch wichtig das zu benennen und es zu sagen
ich glaube ich glaube wir reden jetzt über
eine Politik die gar nicht belehrt werden
muss darüber dass wir eine Begrenzung und
eine Verringerung der ankunftzahlen brauchen
ich übersetze den Steinmeier auf Deutsch die
AFD wirkt jetzt schon und wenn ich mir dann
vorstelle dass der zukünftige Bundespräsident
gewählt wird zur Hälfte mit den Stimmen aus dem
Bundestag wo wir schon Mehrheit haben und den
landesvertretern wo es ganz gut aussieht für uns
ja dann kann ich mir nur sehr schwer vorstellen
dass der neue Bundespräsident sich gegen unsere
Gesetze stellen wird Frau Richterin ich würde
jetzt doch ganz gerne noch mal auf den Antrag
für ein Verbot der AFD zurück wo wo ist sie wo
ist sie denn ja sagen wir so sie hat jetzt ganz
ganz viel Zeit für ihre Kinder sie sie glauben
doch nicht im Ernst dass wenn sie sich weiterhin
aufführen wie die Axt im Walde dass sie dann in
Zukunft noch wieder gewählt werden das ist das
Gute als rechtsextremer muss man nur eine Wahl
[Applaus]
gewinnen was machen wir jetzt also undter
schreibe jetzt diese Petition prüft ein
AFD Verbot ja Petition ist do jetzt zu
spät das ist do eine Satiresendung ich
meine das muss ja nicht Wirklichkeit werden
was diese Clowns hier vorgespielt haben wie
heißt diese Petition nur falls ich das auch
mal googelen möchte prüft ein AFD Verbot wir
haben schon 240 000 Leute unterschrieben
sogar Ärzte guten Tag mein Name ist BAB
ich bin Mitglied der Band die Ärzte mein Name
ist MADI ich bin Arzt und quegan Aktivist hab
zusammen mit dem politikblock volksverpetzer
eine Petition gestartet um die AFD auf ihre
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit hin überprüfen zu
lassen ich habe mich sehr laut und deutlich
für eine Prüfung des Verbots der AFD ausgesprochen
geben sich offen rechtsradikal in Reden und auch
in Wahlkampfprogramm ich möchte das Menschen
verstehen dass ich als Quere Person als Person
die selber schon Diskriminierung erfahren
hat aufgrund der sexuellen Orientierung
aber im Endeffekt alle Menschen die selber schon
Ausgrenzung und Diskriminierung erfahren haben
vor dieser Partei haben Angst vor den Konsequenzen
einer Wahl die dazu führt dass diese Partei
Entscheidungsmacht in diesem Land hat
diese Partei gehört überprüft das war die
Anstalt vergessen was denn na das Abo und
die Glocke was dann war das hier alles
ganz umsonst ich fürchte ja vielleicht
wissen unsere Zuschauer auch selbst wo
sie abonnieren können jetzt nochitere gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr
klug